Are Two Triangles Congruent
Ponding Angles Have to Be
Congruent Ponding Sides Also Have to Be Congruent
All Six Elements of Each Triangle
Three Sides and Three Angles Do We Need to
Know All of Them Not Necessarily to Know If Two Triangles Are Congruent We Don't Need to Compare
All six elements of each triangle There are a few
conditions that will help us to know if two triangles are congruence We need
to construct triangle with sides 3
5 and 7
cm It would look something like this 3 5 and 7
Now let's construct another triangle with
Sides 3 5 and 7
cm This is how it was shaped out 3 5 and 7
cm These two trials will only be cruel If you try
constructing them in your notebook you will see that they will be
of the same shape
and size that your trip a
Condition If Three Sides of a Triangle Are
Respectively Equal to the Three Sides of
Another Triangle The Three Angles Will Surely
Be
Congruent Then Here is an Interesting
Question for You Will the Triple A Congruent
Condition Work Everyone has been asked to construct a
triangle with the  Measures of the
Angles as 45 45 and 90 Degree Triple A
simply means that three angles of each triangle are given
so we draw a triangle that
looks like this The Measures of the Angles are
45 45 and 90 Degree and then was just asked
to construct a  Triangle with the measures of
the angles S 45 45 and
90° The same measures as the angles of the
previous triangle So let's construct a triangle
like this The angles measuring 45 45
and
90° are the triangle right We can clearly see that their
sizes are different  Ch Means They Are
Not Crue So The Pip A Condition For Crue May
And May Not Work It Could Have Worked Because There Was A
Chance The Jar Word Had Done The Act Same Triangle S Jan
But The Triple S K
Will V V Will Luck A  Kiss the Village and In the Gang
[Music]